I was texting reg during the game but
only you know that he would read during
timeouts though reg good morning how
many text messages do you get when
you're calling again that I check during
a timeout yeah
probably half a dozen I have you Mark
Jackson normally text text me I get
about half a dozen you know guys that
are watching it and some ladies that are
watching the games momma do text me
Ryker's watching things like that all
right
I'm watching James Harden and I just
came to the conclusion I don't know if
you can stop him and so the job is to
contain him and we've seen a variety of
Defense's on him if you were going to
help a team devise a defense
give me the ideal defender and then what
do you do to try to contain James Harden
ideal defender would have to be in the
range of six five to six seven with legs
long arms so that would be like a Kawhi
Leonard Paul George and I would kind of
devise what we saw last night the
feistiness of Corey Brewer and then you
brought into smaller TJ McConnell who
picked him up full and really got into
his chest didn't back down and what we
saw late from the Sixers as well is they
started to double-team him 3/4 court and
with Eric Gordon struggling no Chris
Paul no Clint capela let everyone else
beat you so they got the ball out of his
hands and then they just denied him no I
know that's easier said than done and a
lot of teams have done that but the
Sixers made it a point to let James
Ennis do let gerald green to let the
newly acquired Kenneth Faried Nene shoot
all you want we do not care they
struggled last night they only made 11
made threes they averaged 15 on the
season they averaged 44 attempts they
only got up 42 or 43 James Harden at
times was brilliant spectacular but it
was a he was Michael there there was no
Tito Jermaine
the other Jacksons didn't show up and
the Sixers took advantage of that
could you play them hype but my main
defender would have to be with length
long arms so when he does that step back
you can contest' without fouling because
if you're shorter than six five he's
just gonna shoot over you the defender
has to have length could you run a box
in one on him in the pros I guess you
could but at this level you are I guess
required to be able to shoot and a box
in one is it works in college because
usually you have one maybe two really
really good players and everyone else
kind of just you know plays along at the
pro level it's a little bit difficult
because everyone was an all-american in
college
I like playing physical with him and
adding length to it yeah it feels like
he loves contact he likes to know where
you are there's certain guys that they
don't want a body on them and then there
are other guys who are comfortable with
that body because they know where you
are and then how to use that against you
and hardens one of those guys Paulie
brought up an idea and and he said look
I don't want you to jump down my throat
I have a defense that maybe I could do I
could use on the warrior so Paulie if
you'd like to give Reggie your concept
Reggie's has lightly thought through
what if you had kind of like an umbrella
of four guys defending around the
three-point line and then a decent shot
blocker rim protector down low and
basically defended the three almost
exclusively against the Warriors that
probably could have worked before boogie
cousins came back
I think boogie is going to add a
different element once he gets his
basketball legs because he still doesn't
have them so once he's fully integrated
into that team offensively reg go ahead
and go after Paul that's a stupid
nonsense
today's game everybody's trying to do
that with the Warriors
well I'm sure everyone else thought of
doing that too guarding same with
Houston I'm sure if everyone started
them guarding the three-point line but
it's easier says it done the ball head
you've got two great ball handlers even
at Kevin Durant and Steph Curry
so trying to guard the three primarily
especially in transition it's easier
said than done it's in theory that's
great poly sure executed but it's gonna
be too hard to execute something like
that and then watching klay Thompson I
would think clay was easier to guard
because he doesn't dribble he does come
off picks so why how does he get the
looks that are so open it goes by the
name of Steph Curry Kevin Durant and now
boo-ki cousins those guys are gonna draw
a lot of attention and you're focused in
on them and he is constantly in motion
he's a lot like Stefan times he does not
stop running so you know you think if
they're just simple pin downs when he
doesn't get the basketball he continues
to move and it only takes half a second
for him to get his shot off a lot like
Stef I mean that was a that was a
shooting clinic last night that he put
on but we say that about Steph we see
that about Katie at times it this team
and now they started to like one another
okay but watching the Lakers game last
night and and I know they're depleted
but you know there's a lot of guys
missing a lot of games and therefore
that playoff spots gonna be in jeopardy
here how important do you think it is
for the Lakers and does this speed up
the possibility of them trying to bring
in Anthony Davis do they try to salvage
this season by doing something like that
that would be huge if they can get
Anthony Davis I'm hearing rumblings in
New Orleans and the whole finger issue I
granted I think he has hurt one to two
weeks he'll be out but if they get a
chance to get Anthony Davis to play
alongside LeBron James and let's just
say this when LeBron comes back it's not
answering stone they're gonna go on
another run they had just built up
chemistry you saw the beatdown on
Christmas day of the Lakers they had
they had just built up playing together
and playing well when he went down and
what are they now five in ten without
him five and 11 so another intense place
in the Western Conference and no ball
for another month and change and Rondo
is on the verge of coming back it's time
maybe for badger Johnson Robb palinka to
make a big move okay but who are you
gonna give up to me personally Kuzma
cannot be in the deal but I have a
feeling he will be better if I'm the
pelicans I have to have Kuzma I don't
want look I'll take Lonzo ball off your
hands and but I gotta have Kuzma and I
probably asked for heart as well nope I
don't want Ingram you gotta take Ingram
Kuzma you gotta take them all
ball and what's gonna hurt them is Josh
Hart if you want Anthony Davis you have
to give that up for them I know but this
is what we always do we look at one side
of the trade we go boy the Lakers yeah
well give up those guys and you get
Anthony Davis you got to look at it from
new orleans perspective what are we
getting here right you know because if
you're a Laker fan you're like let's
just give up these guys New Orleans
isn't going oh okay they go you know we
want Kuzma or if I don't hear Kyle coos
misnamed then the only call is gonna end
quickly here and then alright it'll be
in the key
we'll be in the deal but who's been the
best player on the Lakers
besides LeBron James too much far Kuzma
he's got to be in the dealers
unfortunately yeah Melo is now free to
roam apparently okay if he can't play
for the Rockets
why can he play for the Lakers I know I
thought that was dead wrong on this I
thought he was gonna have a career
resurgence with the Rockets I thought it
was gonna be perfect for him he is here
playing he didn't have to play defense
he could just cast away three and if you
can't play for Houston
if you can't just run to a corner lit
James Harden hits you on the numbers to
shoot where can you play I mean we're I
don't know okay but if he it's the would
he stay with the Bulls like why why we
go
no the Bulls are not know the Bulls are
uh no he will be a free agent but I'm
trying to think like what here's a spot
maybe maybe if they want to take a
chance a team that is scrambling for the
playoffs that it's already in the
playoffs but they need some identity
some guy to come off the bench and just
absolutely score and he can go home what
about Brooklyn no I don't want to screw
up Rockland I love Brooklyn listen but
you do need come playoff time when the
game slows down I know you've got didn't
witty I know you got DeAngelo Russell
Jared Allen is your shot blocker I get
that but what about a guy that could
just in a half-court throwing the ball
when the game slows down and just get
you buckets you know what I'm thinking
Melo goes back to Syracuse three years
of eligibility same coach one of Coach
comes as I can't I can't have him I
can't he can't play anymore Brooklyn
no I love with Brooklyn I love with
Brooklyn I love what they're doing they
play on my man who has experience on
that team playoff experience no no okay
Melo doesn't have that much playoff
experience but he does have a little I'm
not telling you you got to play him 30
minutes a game I would say 18 to 22 he's
got it first of all he should be happy
he's back in the league and he should be
happy that he's on a young team that's
surging towards the playoffs be humble
be happy ah you know I should ask you
about what happened in New Orleans in
the NFC title game there where you know
we're trying to change the officiating
the approach to the game everything I
don't know if there's been one of those
calls in NBA history where we went oh my
god you just changed the course of a
season or a championship or do you
remember anything as egregious as this I
can only speak from experience and no
one will probably remember this and I
want Paulie to pull this up as I'm
speaking this was not as egregious as to
call in New Orleans that was a non call
but a call against us versus the New
York Knicks Larry Johnson
more point play in the garden yeah was a
disgrace I'm dead serious that was a
disgrace because Antonio Davis found him
on the floor and in the rule and again
the rules were a little bit different
back then
for them to call that a four-point play
and then for us to lose that game
because we went on I think I believe
that was Game one we ended up winning
Game two in the garden we really should
have been up Oh - and coming home and we
ended up losing that series cuz in the
in the playoffs the margin of error is
very it's very low and we still ended up
losing that series but I harken back to
that four-point play and it was a great
shot by by LJ but it wasn't a four-point
play and that non call in the dome
Laak I looked at it from a different
angle there were two zebras on that play
one in front and one in back and for
them both to swallow the flag death has
to sting those players that has to sting
that fan base yeah because that's game
game is over yeah they are headed to the
Super Bowl yeah it's pretty tough I'm
watching the continuation with Larry
Johnson I think it's a good four-point
play I think it's good you alright good
don't get me riled up come on come on
move on move on it's it's time to move
on from this reg you pushed off on Greg
Anthony at the garden you pour you
nudged him you gave him a hardened ugh
and you could get away with that back
then hey that'd be a flagrant one oh my
god poor Greg Anthony I was contact okay
what was worse Jordin pushing off on
Russell to hit the game-winning shot
against the Jazz or you pushing little
Greg Anthony to the floor what looks
worse is because Greg Anthony is five
inches smaller than I so it looks like
me picking on ya you know high school
picking on a middle school kid at least
Russell and Jordan were about the same
height so I didn't look as bad but that
was pretty bad come on Jordan you know
what you did and that was in Utah reg
don't you talk Dutch again
officials swallow their whistle at least
they used to Greg Anthony going down
they were gonna call that they swallow
their whistle the four-point play by LJ
they it's game on players decide the
game what does I'm upset about that
four-point play they swallow their
whistle usually reg will be working he's
got warriors at the Wizards this third
day night and alongside Kevin Harlan
again at 8:00 Eastern it's a great
listen on TNT safe travel now are you
going home to go back to DC I am headed
to Atlanta to do a little bit more work
yeah yeah Studios were on the road it's
rare that I bid out east this long
because I stayed in Indiana then came
from Indiana to Philly now Philly
Atlanta in Atlanta I'm going to wash it
good and I pray one of the big three one
of the big four now one of the big five
for the Warriors they get it going like
they did last night and I suspect it's
going to be Kevin Durant because he's he
grew up from that area in Washington so
I expect him to have a huge game but you
know no John Wall only Bradley bill
what a mess be one of those it's gonna
be one of those kind of night
yeah the wizard Jim mess there may they
had their chance they had their chance
it's over it's over Johnny all right
safe travels reg and I'll text you on
Thursday night thank you I look forward
to your Texas early game all right
bye-bye
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]